je suis Philippe Tabarro je suis
sénateur des Alpes Maritimes au
département
du Sud-Est de la France je suis membre
de la commission du développement
durable d'aménagement du territoire
j'excuse mon président Jean-François
Longeot ainsi que Didier mandeli qui
travaille qui représente mon groupe au
sein de cette commission et puis je suis
plus particulièrement les thématiques de
transport je suis membre du conseil
d'administration de l'Agence de
financement des infrastructures de
transport Lafitte et membre du Conseil
d'orientation des infrastructures le COI
des
institutions des agences que vous
connaissez bien puisque pour la plupart
d'entre vous vous êtes des journalistes
spécialisés sur les questions de
mobilité alors merci d'avoir accepté ce
rendez-vous
je vous le dis d'ores et déjà je vais
vous donner pas mal de chiffres mais ne
vous inquiétez pas il y a un essentiel
qui était en cours de finition que vous
aurez à la à la fin de mon intervention
donc voilà vous n'êtes pas obligé de
noter tous les chiffres
je pense que dans l'essentiel on a voilà
des éléments qui qui vont vous servir
donc
n'hésitez pas si vous avez besoin de
complément nous les demandez nous avons
toute notre équipe du service presse et
de la commission qui est qui est
mobilisée pour répondre à vos questions
et à la suite de cette petite
intervention bien sûr je suis à votre
disposition
je suis heureux de vous retrouver ce
matin pour vous présenter les principaux
résultats de la consultation en ligne
sur l'acceptabilité des zones à faible
émission mobilité dans le cadre de la
mission lancée en mars dernier par la
Commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
du Sénat angelonneur d'être le
rapporteur comme vous le savez les ZFE
qui se sont d'abord appelés les appâts
avant d'être nommé zcr ont été créés par
la loi d'orientation des mobilités là
l'homme de 2019 le principe de ces zones
est définir dans les plus grosses
agglomérations ne respectant pas les
normes de qualité de l'air des schémas
de restriction de circulation des
véhicules les plus polluants selon un
calendrier des modalités choisies par
l'agglomération ou depuis l'adoption de
la loi climat et résiliente loi où
j'étais rapporteur sur le volet
transport et dans les agglomérations qui
dépassent toujours les seuils selon des
modalités qui sont fixées par la loi
l'objectif est bien ici une amélioration
de la qualité de l'air je tiens à le
préciser parce qu'il y a quelques fois
une confusion entre les émissions de
polluants atmosphérique c'est-à-dire de
dioxyde d'azote et de particules fines
et non pas d'effets de gaz à effet de
serre comme on peut l'entendre il s'agit
avant tout ici en ce qui nous concerne
en ce qui concerne ce sujet une question
de santé publique
je rappelle très brièvement
que le Conseil d'État a condamné l'État
par trois fois en 221 et 2022 sous
astreinte de trois fois 10 millions de
d'euros que la Cour de justice l'Union
européenne a condamné la France par deux
fois pour avoir manqué assez obligations
concernant la qualité de l'air je
referme cette parenthèse au combien
importantes cela étant on observe
partout les ZFE sont mises en place
d'importantes inquiétudes et des
incompréhensions et c'est ce que nous
avons cherché à analyser à travers la
consultation en ligne que nous avons
réalisé ces dernières semaines
l'objectif était entre autres de mieux
comprendre le ressenti des Français sur
cette politique publique qui d'une
manière ou d'une autre les affecte dans
leur vie quotidienne la consultation a
été mise en place sur le site du Sénat
pendant un mois exactement du 17 avril
au 14 mai plus précisément il s'agissait
d'un double questionnaire
est composé d'une vingtaine de questions
avec
majorité de questions dites fermées avec
des questions à choix multiples et
quelques questions ouvertes je dis
double puisque l'une des premières
questions posées au répondant consistait
à leur demander s'il répondait en tant
que particulier ou en tant que
professionnel le questionnaire varié
ensuite selon la réponse apportée à
cette question initiale un questionnaire
s'adressait spécifiquement particulier
bien sûr à notre questionnaire dédié aux
professionnels au total et après clôture
de la consultation
51 346 réponse complète ont été
enregistrées je dis complète parce qu'il
y a eu plus de 40 000 réponses
partielles ou les
candidats n'ont pas été au bout du
questionnaire
il s'agit d'un record pour ce type de
consultation et je tiens vraiment à le
souligner que le Sénat organise
régulièrement sur son site à titre
d'exemple au groupe de travail pareil
sur la sécurité routière avait organisé
une consultation sur les 80 km/h en 2018
qui avait récolté 23000 réponses et qui
était le record à l'époque en termes de
consultation il y avait eu
dans ceux qui sont sur la troisième
place du podum c'est ce qui avait
travaillé sur la gratuité des transports
collectifs de 2019 il y avait eu environ
10 000 réponses pour tous les autres
questionnaires on est largement en de ça
donc vous voyez qu'on est on a
pratiquement le double de réponse de la
question qui avait fait grandir à
l'époque et qui avait causé un certain
nombre de déboires au gouvernement sur
la question des 80 km heure
ce succès alors entre parenthèses
vraiment si je puis m'exprimer ainsi
témoigne de l'importance accordée au
déploiement des ETFE pour nos
concitoyens mais aussi de nombreuses
inquiétudes que se dispositif génère
chez eux avant d'en venir plus dans le
détail au résultat eux-mêmes je
souhaiterais tout d'abord souligner
qu'il s'agit bien d'une consultation qui
est basée sur le principe du volontariat
pas de gratification non plus et c'est
pas un sondage statiquement
représentatif de la population française
vous connaissez bien ces questions il
n'y avait pas de panel représentatif il
n'y avait pas le système des quotas donc
voilà on prend avec
le résultat de cette consultation avec
la prudence
qui qui s'y est à cette à ce genre de
consultation cela étant dit nous avons
cherché analysé les grandes tendances
qui se dégagent de plus de 50 et demi de
réponses reçues dans cette perspective
nous sommes appuyés sur le savoir-faire
d'un expert de la donnée un bon français
un Data Scientist
qui a pu réaliser un travail approfondi
permettant de mettre en évidence les
grandes tendances se dégageant des
résultats de la consultation donc vous
pouvez imaginer qu'elles sont profuses
et d'analyser les corrélations entre
différentes réponses c'était
particulièrement ça également l'intérêt
et je tiens à remercier notre expert de
la donnée qui est présent et qui nous a
beaucoup aidé ainsi bien sûr que tous
les administrateurs de notre commission
du Sénat qui sont comme vous le savez à
la fois compétent et particulièrement
dévoué à l'institution
s'agissant d'abord du profil des
répondants nous avons observé une très
forte mobilisation des particuliers qui
représentent 93% des réponses c'est à
dire près de 48 000 réponses
et 7% restants correspondent à des
professionnels
parmi les particuliers ayant participé à
la consultation 48% réside au sein d'une
métropole et 52% au sein d'une commune
périurbaine ou rurale en outre 60%
d'entre eux réside dans ou à proximité
d'une ZFE parmi les 11 rendus
obligatoires par la loi d'orientation
des mobilités il est intéressant de
noter que près d'un quart des répondants
réside dans ou à proximité de la
métropole du Grand Paris
j'en viens à présent principaux
enseignements que nous tirons des
résultats de cette consultation alors à
la fameuse question êtes-vous favorable
à la mise en place des edfe
on va le voir
86% des particuliers ont répondu y être
opposé avec une distinction entre ceux
qui sont tout à fait opposés 69% et ceux
qui sont plutôt opposés 17%
. cette proportion s'élève à 79% pour
les professionnels on voit un petit peu
moins les répondants ont un effet
exprimé un ressenti très majoritairement
négatif à l'encontre du dispositif et
exprime de vivre inquiétudes quant à
impossible creusement des inégalités
sociales et territoriales alors on a
essayé par rapport notamment aux
questions ouvertes de faire ce qu'on
appelle un nuage de mots un Verbatim
c'est plutôt à la mode mais ça ça montre
bien les les réflexions et les propos
exacts tenus par les personnes qui ont
répondu on a lu beaucoup exclusion
sociale discrimination flagrante entre
les citoyens ruptures d'égalité charrues
avant les boeufs
usine à gaz voilà les termes qui sont
revenus très régulièrement
de nombreux particuliers en fait part
d'un sentiment d'injustice critiquant le
fait que les ménages les plus pauvres
déjà contraints de s'éloigner des
agglomérations du fait du prix de
l'immobilier ne pourrait plus rejoindre
les centres vides du fait des
restrictions de circulation imposées en
ZFE sur les 14% qui ont répondu
favorablement qui se disent favorable
aux ETFE vous voyez le nuage de mots
donc parmi les particuliers l'argument
de l'impact des polluants atmosphériques
sur la santé et mise en avant
il est intéressant de noter qu'une
proportion importante de répondant
favorable à la ZFE ont tout de même
évoqué certains problèmes de mise en
œuvre auxquelles se heurte le dispositif
comme l'insuffisance de l'offre de
transport en commun on en reparlera dans
un instant il fait très chaud non
vous permettez que j'enlève la veste
merci
pour aller plus loin l'analyse des
résultats permet d'identifier plusieurs
corrélations intéressantes entre les
réponses apportées à certaines questions
et l'acceptabilité des ade choix très
vous en exposer trois qui sont apparus
par lente en premier lieu on observe un
lien entre le lieu de résidence des
répondants et le degré d'acceptabilité
du dispositif et les mains importants
ainsi seulement 8% des répondants
résidents dans une commune rurale se
sont dit favorables aux ZFE contre 23%
de ceux résidant au centre ville de la
métropole
deuxième point la deuxième corrélation
que nous avons on pouvait s'y attendre
mais on a eu cette confirmation il
existe une corrélation entre le degré
d'acceptabilité des edfe et le fait pour
en répondant de disposer ou non
d'alternatives crédibles à l'usage du
véhicule individuel pour effectuer ses
déplacements ainsi 67 % des répondants
c'estiment disposés de plusieurs
solutions alternatives satisfaisantes à
l'usage du véhicule individuel et ce
sont défavorables à la mise en place des
edfe en revanche seulement 6% des
personnes ne disposant pas de telles
alternatives se sont dit favorables aux
AFE ça paraît clair quand on a à
disposition une alternative crédible on
est plus favorable aux ZF troisième
point les répondants exprimer des
ressentis différents sur la mise en
oeuvre des ade selon la catégorie
socioprofessionnelle vous savez pour
tous les sonders les fameux CSP quelque
chose qui intéresse beaucoup là on a pu
remarquer que 25% des cadres et 28% des
clients ayant pris part à la
consultation ce sont déclarés favorables
aux ZFE et ces chiffres sont supérieurs
à la moyenne des répondants je vous l'ai
dit tout à l'heure c'était 14% des
particuliers qui étaient favorables aux
ETFE on monte jusqu'à 25% au niveau des
cadres et à 28% au niveau des étudiants
à titre de comparaison la proportion des
personnes favorables aux ETFE étaient
plus faibles pour les autres catégories
sociaux pro c'est à dire les artisans et
les commerçants qui sont à peu près à la
moyenne à 15%, les employés qui sont à
11%, les retraités qui sont à 7% et
enfin les ouvriers à 4% catégories pour
laquelle acceptabilité des aida ressort
apparaît la plus basse dans notre
sondage pour autant la part des
personnes défavorables aux ETF est très
majoritaires dans chacune des catégories
socio-professionnelles appréhendées par
la consultation malgré les pics dont je
vous ai parlé sur les cadres et sur les
étudiants par ailleurs la consultation a
permis de mettre en avant les principaux
obstacles identifiés par les concitoyens
particuliers professionnels à la mise en
oeuvre des ZFE quatre obstacles ont été
particulièrement cités par les
répondants c'est important et vous
verrez dans l'essentiel c'est composé
d'un schéma qui arrive en premier c'est
le coût d'acquisition des véhicules
propres qui est mentionné par 77% des
particuliers et 58 des professionnels
comme un obstacle bien sûr le manque
d'accessibilité de la métropole depuis
les zones périurbaines ou rurales
avoisinantes et mises en avant par 51%
des particuliers
une mise en oeuvre trop rapide des
restrictions de circulation obstacles
qui est mise en avant par 47% des
particuliers 36% des professionnels
enfin le manque de pertinence du système
des vignettes critères appliquées au
véhicule et mentionnés par 47% également
des particuliers et 29% des
professionnels comme étant un obstacle
les particuliers ont aussi été 42% à
mettre en avant l'insuffisance de
l'offre de transport en commun dans
l'agglomération comme un des principaux
obstacles à la ZF
je terminerai si vous le permettez en
faisant un focus sur les difficultés de
renouvellement du parc de véhicules
identifié comme le principal obstacle à
la mise en oeuvre des ZFE par les
répondants particuliers professionnels
premièrement s'agissant des particuliers
97% des répondants ont indiqué disposés
d'un véhicule motorisé parmi eux 42%
disposent d'un véhicule
classé critères 3 4 ou 5 ou non classé
et pourrait donc je vous le rappelle à
terme voire à très court terme être
concerné par les restrictions de
circulation j'ajouterai simplement deux
chiffres qui me semble parlant d'une
part 80 pour 3% des particuliers ayant
pris par la consultation estime ne pas
disposer le d'alternatives satisfaisante
à l'usage de leur véhicule individuel
d'autre part 83% des répondants
n'envisage pas de changer de véhicule du
fait de la mise en place des EDF ça
c'est un chiffre important aussi
intéressant ce dernier chiffre semble
démontrer qu'à ce stade de dispositif
des edfe échoue à produire les
changements de comportement attendu
parmi les concitoyens ça se dit ça en
fin des professionnels la problématique
du verdissement des flottes et tout
aussi prégnante 80 6% des répondants ont
indiqué disposés d'au moins un véhicule
à motorisation diesel
45% d'entre eux sont amenés à circuler
dans des ZF différentes de manière
quotidienne et ça c'est un vrai sujet
dont on reparlera la prochaine fois pour
la présentation du rapport mais d'une
certaine harmonisation notamment pour la
logistique et pour les professionnels
alors même que 75% d'entre eux estiment
insuffisamment précises et accessible
des informations relatives aux ZFE qui
les concernent
enfin 70% des professionnels ayant pris
par la consultation juge les aides
visant faciliter l'acquisition de
véhicules peu polluants insuffisante au
regard du coup occasionné on sait d'une
manière générale que la transition est
cher que ces véhicules notamment
électriques sont trois quatre cinq fois
plus cher que les véhicules actuels et
c'est encore plus prégnant chez les chez
les professionnels
voici un substance c'est principal
conclusions que l'on peut tirer des
résultats de cette consultation lancée
dans le cadre de cette mission
d'information je vous rappelle une chose
c'est donner permettent de compléter la
matière mais ça ne sera pas la base
exclusive de notre travail et de la
remise de notre rapport puisque nous
avons fait plus d'une quarantaine
d'auditions et qui ne sont pas terminés
depuis le mois de mars avec le
témoignage de plus de 100 personnes
issues de 12 horizons en particulier des
représentants des agglomérations des
associations des experts de la qualité
de l'air des transporteurs des
représentants du monde économique de la
logistique ou encore des acteurs de la
filière automobile les résultats de la
consultation pourront enrichir ma
réflexion sans pour autant je tiens à le
préciser préjugé des recommandations que
je serai amené à formuler dans le cadre
de mon rapport j'ai également mis à un
point d'honneur à entendre les
présidents des 11 agglomérations et
ayant mis en place une ZFE en
application de la loi d'orientation des
mobilités afin de recueillir et c'était
passionnant le retour d'expérience
pour saisir plus finement les
difficultés qu'ils ont rencontré toutes
les mesures qu'ils ont pu mettre en
oeuvre ce qui a dicté le rythme dans
lequel ils ont mis en place ces ZFE les
mesures d'accompagnement qui ont été
proposées sur les différents territoires
on s'aperçoit on pourra en débattre si
vous avez des questions sur ce sujet ou
lors de la remise du rapport qui a
véritablement
voilà des différences sur la mise en
place et la montée en puissance en
fonction du territoire dans lequel on se
trouve pour ma part j'étais tout
récemment à Strasbourg j'étais
avant-hier à Marseille j'ai également
interrogé à travers un questionnaire
écrit la trentaine d'agglomérations qui
devra se mettre en ZF d'ici 2025 du fait
de la loi climat résilience vous l'avez
claire je pense loi d'orientation des
mobilités 11 métropoles et
principalement celles qui sont par
rapport à qui dépassent les seuils de
pollution
environ
32 33 élémentaires qui sont concernés
par la loi climat et résilience sous
réserve aussi de ne pas être en règle
par rapport à
aux règles concernant la pollution
notamment dans 3 des 5 années qui
précèdent les contrôles opérés en
complément de ce travail j'ai recueilli
des dizaines voire même plus de
contributions écrites de la part des
acteurs que le calendrier de la mission
d'information mission flash c'est rapide
on ne peut pas voir tout le monde par
contre tout le monde nous a écrit a
répondu à nos questionnaires nous avons
sollicité également un intéressant une
étude de droit comparé par rapport à un
certain nombre de pays et de règles
applicables aux ZFE que ce soit en
Italie en Allemagne en Belgique je crois
qu'il y a eu des propositions qui ont
été faites tout récemment en Belgique
notamment de poses j'ai vu ça tout à
l'heure à la buvette du Sénat mais je
n'avais pas le son mais j'ai vu les
Bruxelles et j'ai vu des vignettes
critères donc je pense que là aussi les
choses vont évoluer puisque souvent les
pays étrangers sont cités en exemple
pour avoir parfaitement réussi à mettre
en place leurs adefe
on verra à travers cette étude de droit
comparé si c'est vraiment le cas il me
reste encore quelques auditions à
effectuer avant l'achèvement de des
travaux je pense notamment au ministère
de l'Intérieur pour la question du
contrôle qui est un vrai sujet qui
revient régulièrement
il me reste plus qu'à continuer à
travailler avec toute l'équipe et puis à
vous donner rendez-vous mi-juin très
probablement pour la remise du rapport
en tout cas je suis à disposition pour
répondre si vous en avez à vos questions
je vous propose peut-être la
distribution maintenant si on l'a de
l'essentiel ou plus tard comme vous le
souhaitez et allez-y cher monsieur
Benoît Floch du monde à ce stade alors
j'ai bien compris que le que le rapport
est à venir mais à ce stade est-ce que
les ces chiffres là à vos yeux
comment dire est-ce que ça condamne le
dispositif est-ce que vous dites il faut
faire autre chose où il faut en tout cas
il faut faire autrement
quel est votre première conclusion
finalement alors
l'objectif de cette de cette conférence
de presse c'était vraiment de vous
présenter chez pratiquement de matière
brute alors pas totalement de manière
brute parce qu'il y a eu un travail
énorme de notre
de notre expert de données mais je
voulais vraiment rester sur ce constat
je vais par contre être très clair et
très franc avec vous le ressenti qu'on a
eu sur les territoires les différentes
auditions qu'on a pu avoir avec les
acteurs qui sont confrontés à la mise en
place de ces zones affaiblissement
nous montre les difficultés qui existent
aujourd'hui
et c'est quelque chose qu'au Sénat on
avait anticipé quand on a étudié la loi
climat et résilience il y a un petit peu
plus de d'un an et demi pratiquement
deux ans maintenant nous avons voté un
certain nombre de mesures notamment au
niveau du calendrier on trouvait que le
calendrier était un petit peu resserré
au niveau de l'accompagnement où on a
été des fervent partisans du prêt à taux
zéro pour aider les foyers les plus en
difficulté à opérer cette transition
au niveau des véhicules électriques et
c'est vrai que lors de la commission
mixte paritaire on n'a pas eu un succès
extraordinaire auprès de nos collègues
députés alors c'était les CMP de
l'époque quand je dis de l'époque
c'était qu'il y avait une
un rapport politique qui était un petit
peu différent des des CMP qui sont
maintenant fort connus depuis une
fameuse loi concernant les retraites
tout ça pour vous dire que on avait
anticipé les difficultés qui remontent
aujourd'hui on n'a pas eu une écoute
extraordinaire des collègues députés de
l'époque ou du gouvernement avec
notamment madame Pompili qui était au
banc à l'époque sur ces questions madame
pompidier qu'on a été ravie
d'auditionner parce que
on a appris entre temps qu'elle avait
également en tant que parlementaire en
mission un rapport à remettre sur cette
question des FFE avec laquelle on a
échangé et elle nous a dit qu'elle était
elle aujourd'hui plus dans le cadre de
son rapport sur quelque chose en termes
européens de droit comparés et qui
pouvait avoir quelques corrélations avec
le nôtre mais pas totalement et surtout
dans les exemples étrangers
ce projet ça condamne pas le dispositif
86% de rejet je le rappelle d'une
consultation volontaire on n'est pas sur
un sondage représentatif
je n'ai pas de doute sur le fait que
certains peut-être ont voulu se
mobiliser ou faire porter une certaine
voix bien qu'on ait été très vigilant
sur quelques contributions qui nous
semblaient quasi
identiques sur les questions
sur les questions ouvertes et qu'on a
souhaité ne pas avoir figuré quand on
clairement pensé que c'était du
copier-coller mais on vous parle de
quelques exemples quand il y avait 20 30
contributions
identiques en copier-coller on les a
tout de suite sorti quand je dis à 51300
et quelques et je parle sous le contrôle
de notre expert des données c'est
vraiment des personnes qui l'ont fait de
leur propre chef alors suggéré peut-être
par un certain nombre de vos articles
merci d'avoir rel la consultation vous
l'avez fait vous avez été entendu
donc oui la question se pose les
chiffres interpellent quelque part après
moi j'ai conscience aussi que si le
gouvernement à travers la loi
d'orientation des mobilités et la loi
climat est résilience a pris ses
décisions c'est quelque part dans le
contexte international qu'on connaît
dans le contexte national et je vous ai
rappelé à la fois la condamnation de la
France au niveau européen la
condamnation de la France par le Conseil
d'État c'est aussi des sujets de santé
publique à prendre en compte de décès
prématurés et autres donc
de maladies que génère cette pollution
mais voilà je crois que
l'objectif de notre rapport sera de
prendre en compte ce qui paraît évident
aujourd'hui un manque d'information
un manque de clarté
un manque probablement d'harmonisation
un manque probablement de coordination
ou de synchronisation sur toutes ces
mesures et un impératif de santé
publique et je dis bien de santé
publique qui qui demeure
plusieurs petites questions donc sur les
réponses identiques vous m'avez répondu
sur la majorité de particuliers comment
vous l'expliquez est-ce que vous est-ce
que déjà au niveau des professionnels
qui ont répondu est-ce que c'est plutôt
des individuels ou est-ce que c'est des
fédérations qui représentent des groupes
de professionnels et est-ce que s'ils se
sont moins mobilisés c'est parce qu'ils
sont tout simplement moins nombreux ou
c'est parce que vous les aviez déjà
entendu dans le cadre de vos auditions
et du coup ouais je pense que c'est
votre deuxième réflexion après
vous verrez j'ai posé la question comme
vous d'un côté on a des professionnels
et les particuliers mais dans les
particuliers vous verrez qu'il y a des
dans les catégories
socioprofessionnelles des particuliers
on a demandé la profession du
particulier et on retrouve des personnes
qui sont des artisans et autres alors
est-ce que c'est parce qu'ils ne sont
pas concernés dans le cadre de leur
activité professionnelle est-ce qu'il ne
répondent pas un certain nombre de
marchés qui ont lieu dans les ZF
marché public bien sûr voilà la question
la question peut se poser mais c'est
vrai qu'on a accès beaucoup
nos auditions sur les les transports de
marchandises tout en ayant vu tous les
présidents de
métropole et j'ai eu l'occasion de vous
le rappeler mais la question de la
logistique est à être un vrai souci est
un souci encore je dirais supplémentaire
par rapport à aux particuliers
parce que c'est revoir l'organisation de
de toutes les villes quelque part c'est
une une transition qui est plus
compliqué en termes de de véhicules
disponibles il y a le coût du véhicule
aussi alors le coût du véhicule pour des
grandes entreprises avec des grandes
flottes c'est c'est un problème mais
c'est pas un problème qui est totalement
le prix ne peut pas être totalement
rédhibitoire par contre pour les plus
petits artisans pour les véhicules
utilitaires légers il y a un vrai sujet
sur le manque de d'offres aujourd'hui
sur du transport des carbonés comme se
pose la question si je l'ai évoqué très
rapidement on en reparlera de
l'harmonisation des règles on a
rencontré des associations
des chambres de sur l'artisanat le
commerce ils nous disent on a certaines
nos artisans qui travaillent trois dans
trois ou quatre ZF quotidiennement on en
avait parlé notamment sur le secteur de
d'Auvergne Rhône-Alpes entre Lyon
Saint-Étienne Grenoble-Valence les
personnes se retrouvent avec des
dérogations différentes des règles
différentes on a auditionné Xavier
Bertrand aussi qui a si ZFE en devenir
sur sur son territoire très proche les
unes des autres et là aussi où va se
poser le problème d'une certaine
harmonisation et synchronisation ce qui
est aussi un vrai problème parce que
d'un côté nous l'idée que le territoire
puisse s'organiser et puisse adapter par
rapport à la fois à leur taux de
pollution à la fois au moyen public
qu'ils ont pu mettre en place sur
l'information sur des agences
du climat qui existe comme à Strasbourg
sur une concertation avec les habitants
et d'un autre côté on ne peut pas non
plus ne pas avoir peut-être un
référentiel commun pour un certain
nombre notamment de professionnels pour
leur éviter de renoncer à aller dans les
ZFE et renoncer à des chantiers à
à des marchés publics le cas échéant
parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas s'y rendre
du fait des difficultés dernier exemple
il est tout récent on était à Marseille
il y a plein de propositions
intéressantes au niveau de de jeunes
entreprises aidé par la métropole sur
tout ce qui touche au vélo cargo qui est
une bonne solution des fois pour le
dernier kilomètre pour un certain nombre
de types de livraisons mais bon voilà un
artisan c'est plus difficile de de le
faire travailler en vélo cargo il y a
quand même quelques quelques raisons
tout ça pour dire que les artisans n'ont
pas été oubliés les professionnels en
général d'autant plus que
mais ils sont très bien représentés on a
pu l'entendre mais d'autant plus que
c'est le secteur ou la ou la
disponibilité de véhicules des carbonés
n'arrivent pas ou très peu on a
longtemps parlé de et on en parle
toujours de la question de de
l'hydrogène de la question etc etc et on
sait que voilà il y a encore un petit
peu de temps pour opérer cette
transition et notamment de préférence
une transition européenne voire
française ce qui serait intéressant qui
ferait plaisir aux présidents de la
République il y a enfin parlé de ce
sujet il y a quelques jours
oui en ligne pardon on avait une
question ici aussi
pour capital merci beaucoup dans les
retours d'expérience on entend aussi
parfois les difficultés pour mettre en
oeuvre les LFE pour pour les appliquer
je crois dans l'invitation vous
mentionnez le fait que que c'était pas
toujours respecté ce que vous avez des
données là dessus ou est-ce que c'est
apparu dans dans vos auditions merci
beaucoup
la question la vraie question
aujourd'hui c'est la question du
contrôle voilà
je dirais que on sent que les choses
vont être compliquées
mais comme il n'y a pas de contrôle ou
très peu de contrôle
bonhomme voilà il y a les non je peux
pas les appeler des bons citoyens mais
quelques citoyens qui qui sont bien
faits qui anticipent ces questions
mais mais ensuite
voilà le jour où les contrôles arrivent
c'est différent
est-ce que sur certains territoires les
habitants sont bien au courant que dans
moins de deux ans s'il est taux de
pollution restent aussi important dans
leur territoire ils seront 42% et ça
monte jusqu'à 52% dans les
arrondissements les plus pauvres de
Marseille et qui sont en centre-ville
qui sont en ZF je pense au troisième
arrondissement est-ce que 52% des
habitants sont au courant d'ici deux ans
ils doivent
laisser leur véhicule
actuels et c'est même pas le vendre
puisque voilà c'est véhicules non plus
d'espérance de vie ensuite parce qu'ils
ne seront autorisés dans dans aucune
partie de notre territoire donc voilà la
question du contrôle est très compliqué
tout le monde se
voilà
c'est exonère de cette question parce
que ça fait
plaisir à personne de verbaliser
on a une expérience très récente on
parlait des 80 km/h tout à l'heure on
sait que ça ce que ça a généré donc par
rapport à ces questions c'est c'est
vraiment un sujet on a envie d'entendre
le ministère de l'Intérieur qui a
repoussé régulièrement
les contrôles maintenant on nous avait
parlé de lecture automatisée des plaques
de dispositif qui seraient prêts au
deuxième semestre 2024 pour tout vous
dire on n'a pas eu encore l'audition du
ministre et on espère la voir avant la
remise du rapport mais ce sera un vrai
sujet aussi sur
la clarté de la mesure mais c'est ce qui
peut générer ce qui est sous-jacent
aujourd'hui mais le déclenchement d'un
certain nombre de difficultés ça paraît
évident
il y a Madame et Monsieur
la tendance actuelle c'est plutôt au
recul on voit que les grandes métropoles
ont plutôt tendance aujourd'hui à
reculer les calendriers
alors
oui vous savez que la loi a fixé un
certain nombre de règles à la fois la
loi d'orientation des mobilités à fixer
des échéances toujours avec en ligne de
mire l'idée est-ce que le territoire
concerné est en dépassement ou pas voilà
mais donc ça c'est un premier axe il y a
un calendrier qui est fixé et après je
dirais le schéma de restriction plus
précis des différentes vignettes
critères ce sont les métropoles en
question qui les mettent en place il y
avait des métropoles qui ont été
particulièrement
volontariste optimiste
ou qui ont pensé voilà juste titre qu'il
fallait faire un effort et que ça
paraissait évident et qui ont mis des
calendriers assez resserrés et qui sont
revenus sur ce calendrier et qui
reviennent sur ce calendrier
et là c'est un sujet quand même
intéressant on est plus sur un clivage
politique c'est-à-dire que allez on a
tendance à croire moi penser que les
présidents d'exécutifs qui sont plutôt
de couleur verte ou en tout cas qui qui
ont voilà mis l'écologie au cœur de leur
programme électoral sont enclins avancés
sur ces sujets on s'aperçoit que même se
rendent se retrouvent confrontés à la
situation dont j'ai parlé il y a un
instant et sont en train de revoir leur
calendrier
on a entendu également le président
Ollier qui nous a dit voilà il y avait
des objectifs notamment sur la fin du
diesel sur le Grand Paris qui donc des
critères de qui qui
devait arriver avant 2030 de manière
à devancer ce qui était prévu dans la
loi
et je pense que c'est pas aujourd'hui
sa préoccupation principale et il est en
train de voir comment avec l'accord des
autres mères et notamment de la mère de
Paris revoir ce calendrier donc il y a
un principe de réalité aujourd'hui
auquel sont confrontées les présidents
d'exécutif quel que soit leur étiquette
politique et quel que soit leur volonté
ou leur bonne volonté de mettre en place
ces mesures donc ça on en a bien
conscience
voilà je vais pas vous le citer pour pas
le mettre dans la difficulté mais il y a
un président d'exécutif plutôt plutôt
d'une majorité
verte qui nous disait il y en a presque
marre de cette écologie punitive donc
il y a quelques fois quand vous avez à
vos fenêtres des motards en colère qui
qui
manifeste voilà leur mécontentement ou
d'autres administrés et notamment quand
ça touche aussi
le cœur de votre action tourné vers le
social et c'est ce qu'on s'est dit vous
l'avez vu à travers les chiffres ce sont
les personnes qui sont socialement sur
le plus en difficulté qui auront le plus
d'efforts à faire au niveau de cette
transition mais quelquefois aussi c'est
les personnes qui sont le plus
confrontées aux pollutions
je voulais revenir sur cette histoire de
contrôle est-ce que vous avez eu accès
aux rapports de Raphaël bertholt et vous
aviez l'air de remettre en cause le fait
que le contrôle sera fait par le Lapi
est-ce qu'il y a une autre solution qui
qui apparaît aujourd'hui ouais même moi
je veux pas me prononcer sur le contrôle
tant que je n'ai pas eu le ministère de
l'intérieur ce qui sera le cas
probablement la semaine prochaine
problème du contrôle comme on l'a dit
on reconnaît on est français on va se
dire les choses on sait que si les
mesures faciles y a pas de contrôle les
mesures vont mourir de leur belle-more
et personne ne les appliquera voilà
alors il y a aujourd'hui beaucoup et
c'est le terme qui revient chez les
présidents de la pédagogie la pédagogie
ça veut dire enverbalise pas est-ce que
la pédagogie a vraiment lieu quelquefois
non mais comment vous voulez expliquer à
Marseille aujourd'hui que des policiers
dans le contexte
explosif qu'on peut connaître je dis
Marseille comme d'autres mais les
policiers probablement autre chose à
faire aujourd'hui dans certaines
métropoles que d'aller contrôler les
vignettes critères c'est ce que nous en
dit les préfets à chaque fois quand on
faisait un déplacement aussi on va voir
le préfet nous dit moi les effectifs ils
sont mobilisés sur sur d'autres
questions que les vignettes critères
même si on est persuadé que que c'est
important que c'est un vrai sujet
il y a je le verrai mardi matin mais le
président
estrosianisme qui dit c'est une mesure
qui nous vient de l'État moi je mettrai
pas un policier municipal pour contrôler
les vignettes critères voilà donc c'est
une mesure d'État que ce soit la
nationale de le faire je veux pas que
mes municipaux aillent contrôler les
vignettes critères voilà la
problématique sur la question du
contrôle est-ce que la lecture
automatisée des plaques est un bon
système
les radars s'appelaient pas trop en
France on le sait
il y a une difficulté technique quand
même c'est à dire que les
ZF ont été mises en place sont toutes
différentes les unes de les autres ou
les unes des autres ce que la loi
permettait certains ont choisi un
périmètre réduit d'autres un périmètre
beaucoup plus large ça c'est une
première chose certains
appliquent la zone affaiblissement 7
jours sur 7 24 24
et avec très peu de dérogations et
d'autres c'est 5 jours sur 7 c'est la
journée pas le soir et c'est un carnet
on va parler l'ancienne de dérogation de
tickets de 12 voyages de 24 voyages de
48 voyages la possibilité aux petits
rouleurs de faire un certain nombre de
kilomètres il y a eu alors ils se sont
organisés je jette surtout pas la pierre
au contraire au président d'exécutif qui
ont essayé en lien avec leurs
administrés grâce à d'innombrables
réunions de concertation que quelque
part est un n'a pas fait alors l'état
n'est pas là pour faire des réunions de
concertation probablement même si ça a
été fait lors du débat public par le
président lui-même mais pas bien sûr au
quotidien mais voilà il y a une
puissance quand même une force de l'État
à travers notamment la l'information je
pense à tous les spots télévisés qu'on a
pu avoir pendant la période du du du
covid est-ce que vous avez vu un poste
enfin une voilà sur une télé
le gouvernement qui finançait quelque
chose pour montrer la gravité de la
situation en France de santé publique
expliquer pourquoi on demandait à des
personnes de transformer leur véhicule
de le vendre ou de faire du repas modal
parce que la base aussi c'est ça c'est
le report modal voilà donc quelques
éléments qui montrent que la question du
contrôle est au cœur du dispositif et
qu'elle est loin à l'heure où je vous
parle et j'espère en avoir un petit peu
plus lors de la remise du rapport une
réponse parce que voilà on peut pas
tourner
le dos à cette question de clarification
la clarification c'est l'information et
c'est le contrôle pour moi
de Localtis je ne sais pas si vous avez
eu connaissance d'un sondage récent qui
a été commandé par le Cercle des élus
locaux auxquels participent d'ailleurs
certains de vos collègues sénateurs et
qui montrait que
majoritairement enfin pour les deux
tiers les Français étaient favorables
aux principes des des feux et que
naturellement ce qui ce qui coince c'est
le dispositif d'accompagnement donc je
alors il y a différents sondages aussi
et j'ai bien pris la peine de dire que
là on était sur une consultation nous
les personnes qui ont répondu
à cette consultation était 97 pour 100
d'entre elles à connaître le dispositif
des aidafe disons qu'on connaît donc
c'est des personnes qui ont
l'information nécessaire sur ce sujet
précis elle s'intéresse au sujet c'est
pour ça qu'elles sont venus répondre
après quand vous êtes dans un sondage
c'est des citoyens qui sont tirés selon
la méthode des quotas sur l'ensemble du
territoire
autant d'hommes que de femmes ou 50 de
tous les CSP
répartition quelquefois géographique et
autres donc des personnes qui ne sont
peut-être pas confrontés aujourd'hui ou
qui n'ont pas l'information nécessaire
sur la ZF je pense qu'il y a une grande
différence entre
le
les enquêtes quand les personnes sont
plutôt au courant de ce qui va se passer
des personnes qui ne sont pas de masse
que vous êtes pour sauver la vie de 40
plus de 40 000 personnes qui meurent de
la pollution
euh voilà bien sûr que tout le monde va
être favorable à ça est-ce que vous êtes
prêt à à donner
à jeter je dis pas avant moi votre
véhicule d'ici 2 ans
je pense pas que quand on est les mêmes
chiffres je pense pas qu'on est les
mêmes chiffres donc si on arrive à
expliquer alors est-ce que peut-être de
bonne foi ces personnes disent ben voilà
c'est un effort moi j'ai intégré dans ma
vie qui doit avoir une transition
écologique j'ai essayé de regarder
comment je pouvais acheter un véhicule
électrique j'ai essayé de regarder qui
pouvait m'aider un bonus écologique une
prime à la casse une aide peut-être de
la collectivité dans laquelle j'habite
un prêt à taux zéro que le Sénat a voulu
mettre en place mais que le gouvernement
n'a accepté de mettre en place que de
manière expérimentale avec des
micro-crédits qui a développé le Secours
Catholique notamment et autres donc
cette voilà ce sujet
je dirais plus on connaît la ZF et moi
on est favorable quand même voilà on va
on va se le dire comme ça on va se le
dire comme ça
là vous êtes vous touchez au but vous
avez quand même beaucoup de matière
quels sont les là où les préconisations
que je dessine bien essayé mais je vais
pas vous répondre non voilà
c'est vraiment vraiment pas terminé je
pense vous en avoir déjà dit beaucoup
sur l'esprit on ne peut pas ne pas
prendre en compte les chiffres qu'on a
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas ne pas
prendre en compte
l'impératif de santé publique qui existe
après trouver un voilà une voix une
ligne de crête
par rapport à ça c'est ce qu'on va
essayer probablement de faire sur les
préconisations qu'on va faire ce qui
semble évident voilà je veux pas que ce
soit déjà perçu comme une une conclusion
mais ce qui semble évident c'est qu'il y
a une désynchronisation entre les
schémas de restriction entre le
calendrier et entre l'avancée des
alternative parce que je connais un
petit peu la question des des
alternatives et des transports en commun
je sais que le gouvernement est un
membre du Conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures a repris beaucoup de nos
préconisations et un plan bornes sur le
ferroviaire notamment pour 2040 on
devrait on j'attends de savoir par quel
véhicule législatif mais investir un
milliard de plus par an dans le
ferroviaire tout en continuant à
financer les projets de transport en
site propre sur sur les territoires il y
a les projets qui semblent être plutôt
bien perçu et repris de Cara au niveau
de service de mon collègue du regret
enfin qu'il a pu présenter et qui
fonctionne déjà sur certains territoires
notamment Aix-Marseille ou on était
présent il y a tous les projets qui vont
être livrés sur la couronne parisienne
et qui ont été menées à bien par par la
Société du Grand Paris donc oui il y a
des efforts qui sont faits au niveau des
transports en commun mais vous le savez
comme moi vous êtes tous des
spécialistes de transport le transport
et notamment le ferroviaire c'est un
temps long pardon les RER métropolitains
ou les services et express régionaux
métropolita je dois avoir le président
du lésier de l'Assemblée nationale tout
à l'heure pour qu'on coordonne un petit
peu les choses peut-être par rapport au
texte qu'il souhaite porter sur ce sujet
ça va prendre du temps ça va prendre du
temps le la possibilité de faire baisser
le reste à charge pour les personnes qui
souhaiteraient ne pas utiliser le report
modal mais acquérir leur véhicule parce
que là aussi vous travaillez un certain
nombre d'entre vous pour pour des revues
automobiles je vais pas vous raconter à
vous l'histoire d'amour entre les
Français leur voiture et la difficulté
que ça peut représenter de leur dire ben
tu lui dis au revoir tu la reverras plus
jamais et puis surtout tu
on achète pas une nouvelle et là
l'industrie automobile vous dit oui on
va avancer on a beaucoup avancé ça va
mieux à chaque fois mais voilà on a en
tête que on pourra plus fabriquer de de
véhicules en
thermique mais il y a quand même un
certain temps je vous parle même pas de
tout ce qui est logistique de reste à
financer je vous ai cité un certain
nombre d'exemples donc je pense que
l'idée surtout c'est de pouvoir
permettre de synchroniser
l'accélération
l'accélération de toutes ces mesures
d'accompagnement
pour l'acquisition pour développer la
filière développer la vitaillement aussi
on était super content avec nos bornes
récemment il y en a encore il y a encore
du travail et de se dire que pour
certains les aidefe c'est maintenant
voilà il y a déjà des territoires où il
y a une application sur les critères
simples les critères 4 et puis pour les
principales communes de notre de notre
pays que ce soit Paris Lyon Marseille
probablement la fin des critères 3 en
je citer l'exemple du troisième
arrondissement de Marseille excusez-moi
de le stigmatiser mais je ça correspond
à 52% des véhicules
Alexandre Tesla magazine moi je voulais
savoir déjà si vous preniez en compte
les retours de
des pays de l'Union européenne par
rapport aux ETFE et comment vous allez
du coup les prendre en compte
ecoutez oui comme je vous l'ai dit à une
étude sur le droit comparé je veux pas
la présenter aussi on a toujours
l'habitude de dire et moi je pars de ce
constat on nous dit vous savez les ZFE
ça marche à l'étranger pourquoi ça
marcherait pas en France voilà tout le
monde dit ça moi je veux le vérifier je
suis en train d'essayer de le vérifier
est-ce que c'est vrai est-ce que c'est
pas vrai et à quel niveau donc bien sûr
que cette étude de droit comparé si
demain ce qui marche dans un de des pays
européens un peu être appliqué à la
France j'en serais le plus heureux après
quand on dit ça on ne rentre pas
quelquefois dans le détail et puis on va
pas se le cacher non plus il y a
certains pays européens qui ont préféré
un report modal qu'on n'a pas en France
il y a une habitude sur les modes de
transport doux dans certains pays on
fait plus de vélo
dans les Pays-Bas que en France
je sais pas je vous donne pas un scoop
mais voilà il y a une organisation
en Autriche en Suisse en Suède qui n'a
rien à voir avec la nôtre donc oui ce
sera intéressant de voir et on donnera
des éléments mais
est-ce que cette phrase de dire ça se
fait ailleurs alors ça va se faire en
France je sais pas si elle est
totalement vrai ou si elle ne elle
existe il y a des vérités mais est-ce
qu'elle ne peut pas être un petit peu
atténuée par contre si vous êtes de
Tesla magazine s'il vous plaît baisser
le prix des Tesla voilà si vous avez un
si vous connaissez le grand patron et
comme il était en France il y a pas
longtemps la base aussi c'est le coup
des véhicules électriques c'est le coût
des véhicules électriques alors il y a
la Dacia maintenant qui va baisser sous
les qui descend sous les sous les 20000
euros il y a voilà je sais qu'il y a qui
a des efforts quand même conséquent il y
a une vraie concurrence avec avec
différents véhicules mais le coût le
coup est rédhibitoire et on peut
augmenter bien sûr toutes les aides et
c'est très bien de le faire mais
objectivement le plus important c'est
que le coût baisse pour que le reste a
financé soit le moins important possible
oui
n'hésitez pas à
je voulais savoir si vous aviez des
données géographiques sur les répondants
est-ce que vous avez perçu des écarts
dans le ressenti des différentes
agglomérations est-ce que il y en a
certaines qui se dégagent plus que
d'autres dans le ressenti négatif ou
est-ce qu'à l'inverse dans certaines il
y a moins de comment dire de
de présence de réponse négatives non les
seuls données géographiques on a je
parle sous le contrôle du
data scientist
les seuls données qu'on a c'est la c'est
l'origine des répondants
et c'est ce qu'on vous a dit en gros sur
les particuliers un quart viennent de la
de la de la région parisienne la
couronne parisienne donc ça la
corrélation qu'on peut faire c'est celle
là et après les autres sont je dirais
j'ai la carte là mais répartie de
manière plutôt égale sur sur les autres
ZF potentiels le point est quand même
fort près d'un quart des personnes qui
ont répondu sont des Parisiens
petite grande moyenne courroie
on n'a pas on n'a pas ça mais dans le si
vous voulez alors
j'ai fait foi sur les entretiens qu'on a
pu avec les présidents de de
d'exécutif et de métropole
un petit peu essayer d'avoir un avis
objectif sur la perception qu'ils
avaient alors
tout son conscience que le fait que les
contrôles ne soient pas très nombreux et
très offensifs voilà fait que les choses
sont moins catastrophiques qu'il pouvait
le penser à l'origine mais ils savent
que demain s'ils mettent en place voilà
une verbalisation quelle qu'elle soit ça
posera un certain nombre de problèmes
après il y a peut-être des territoires
où la formation a mieux passé ou la
concertation a été mieux faite
et puis où il y a une je le disais pour
d'autres pays européens mais c'est vrai
en France allez je vais prendre mon
exemple le transport en commun d'une
manière générale et plus développée plus
utilisé autour de Strasbourg que que par
exemple autour de de Marseille qui a
beaucoup de de retard qui est en train
de rattraper son retard ou que d'autres
territoires donc
certains territoires sont plus en avance
ont déjà une conscience écologique qui
est peut-être un petit peu plus forte
qu'ailleurs et déjà ont intégré les
modes doux le transport en commun de
manière très naturelle et peut-être
aussi ont une offre supplémentaire à
d'autres territoires qui ont été un
petit peu abandonnés au niveau de du
développement des transports en commun
donc je pense que c'est ça le critère
principal d'acceptabilité c'est bien sûr
le niveau social on l'a vu à travers
cette enquête voilà les plus pauvres et
ceux qui habitent en dehors des ZFE sont
les plus défavorables aux ZFE voilà ceux
qui ont un petit peu plus de moyens qui
habitent dans les ZF et qui ont des
transports en commun développés ils sont
plus favorables ça explique tout et je
pense que c'est une constante qu'on peut
avoir sur tous les territoires mais qui
est
plus ou moins importantes en fonction du
développement
d'un état d'esprit et de transport en
commun dans les territoires qui sont
assez disparates en France il faut bien
le reconnaître
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est une
bombe sociale à retardement ces élèves
alors bon les termes j'en ai entendu et
et
je vais pas dire qu'on a filtré mais
dans les nuages de mots on n'a pas voulu
mettre trop de voilà trop de mots qui
que la bienséance voilà il y a on a eu
un petit peu de tout on a eu un petit
peu tout donc on a eu les zones à fort
emmerdement
on a eu bon les zones à forte exclusion
vous le connaissez également c'est
quelque chose dont on a déjà parlé dans
cette maison voilà il y a des termes pas
très sympa qui ont été trouvés c'est le
c'est le moyen pour c'est les mesures
anti banlieusard c'est les mesures
anti-provinciaux enfin voilà c'est ça
c'est des des termes qui sont revenus
dans les questions dans les questions
ouvertes après
j'ai envie de vous dire quelque part oui
très probablement mais quel sujet
aujourd'hui dans notre pays
ne pose pas un certain nombre de
problèmes on a eu voilà le la question
des gilets jaunes et c'est souvent
comparé on nous dit des gilets jaunes
sont venus par rapport au carburant par
rapport aux 80 km/h
là parce qu'on touchait à la voiture là
aussi on touche à la voiture donc on ne
peut pas ne pas voir une similitude pour
un certain nombre de de
personnes qui analysent un petit peu
l'état de l'opinion
donc ça ça paraît aussi voilà
et puis il y a l'aspect aussi de l'état
aujourd'hui du pays il n'y a pas un
ministre qui peut sortir tranquillement
aujourd'hui dans une visite
ministérielle sans être mis à mal par
rapport à un climat qui était tendu déjà
et qui est encore plus tendu depuis la
question de la retraite ça c'est pas une
interprétation de ma part c'est un fait
aujourd'hui qui alors est-ce que ça va
durer à ce que ça va pas durer mais en
tout cas il est évident que le contexte
social
aujourd'hui est très compliqué est-ce
que ce sera le cas en 25 encore si le
calendrier n'est pas modifié ou dans les
trois plus grandes agglomérations Paris
Lyon Marseille
on demande à 40% des personnes de
changer la leur véhicule sous peine de
prendre 68 euros tous les jours si elle
rentre dans la ZFE contrôlée par un
lecteur automatisé des plaques voilà je
vous fais le scénario catastrophe
peut-être ou en tout cas qui si
aujourd'hui on modifie pas les choses et
quelque part le scénario qui qui attend
nos concitoyens donc nous l'idée si on
s'est saisi du problème au Sénat c'est
qu'on veut pas en arriver là si on va
faire des propositions dans quelques
dans quelques jours c'est que on a
vraiment
envie de pas voilà créer une bombe
sociale comme vous l'avez appelé
supplémentaire alors qu'il en existe
déjà quelques-unes en ce moment avec des
grenades qui sont relativement
dégoupillés
c'est 68 oui pour les pour les
particuliers c'est 135 pour les
pour les pour les camions
alors il y a une différence
d'analyses entre est-ce que c'est 68
quand vous n'avez pas la bonne vignette
critères ou est-ce que c'est 68
également si vous n'avez pas de vignette
critères du tout mais en tout cas dans
les territoires où cette appliqué pour
les quatre et les cinq c'est 68 pour
celles qui ne sont plus acceptés dans
les dans les dans les ZF
est-ce qu'en visio on a on a fatigué
tout le monde on a encore des survivants
de caravisiac je voulais savoir dans vos
préconisations est-ce que vous englobrez
également les moteurs thermiques qui
normalement ne réexister en 2002 sont
plus commercialisés en 2035 de critères
1 et 2 ce que vous avez parlé de
véhicule électrique mais rien sur le
permis merci
l'idée pour moi l'idée c'est de c'est à
la priorité qu'on aille vers du report
modal si c'est pour retrouver 40
millions de véhicules électriques ça
réglera pas notamment un certain nombre
de problèmes de congestion automobile
c'est à polluera moins un petit peu
moins mais mais ça posera tout autant de
enfin des problèmes différents mais ça
posera encore des problèmes donc l'idée
bien sûr
report modal vers le transport en commun
il faut que ce soit la priorité
deuxièmement bien sûr que
la la
survie des critères
à voir deux si le calendrier reporté va
permettre à un marché d'occasion de
fonctionner et de continuer à
fonctionner sur ces véhicules donc tant
que les critères 2 et les critères 1 ne
sont pas
interdits il est possible d'opérer la
compétition quand vous avez aujourd'hui
voiture vignette 5 ou 4 de d'acheter un
critère de haut c'est tout à fait
possible donc soit aller sur
l'électrique soit critères 2 ou 1
d'occasion en sachant que les choses ne
sont pas claires encore sur les critères
2 notamment par rapport à des
territoires qui avaient annoncé qu'elle
mettait fin des 25 ou 26 26 pour Paris
peut-être 25 ce qui est plus le cas 28
pour dans 28 pour Paris pareil pour pour
Strasbourg mais j'ai bien compris que
les territoires
je veux pas parler à leur place mais
mais je suis pas persuadé que que parmi
les 11 territoires qu'on a qu'on a vu
tous vont interdire les vignettes
critères 2 c'est-à-dire globalement le
diesel avant 2030 donc il y a quand même
une vie pour pour les vignettes critères
2 et critères 1 bien sûr d'occasion donc
ça peut être pour pour les personnes une
mesure à moindre coût peut-être que
d'acheter un véhicule électrique tant
que les aides ne sont pas augmentées
tant que le coût ne baisse pas et et
bien sûr je redis la priorité c'est
moins de véhicules et moins de véhicules
c'est du report modal vers les
transports en commun
on est bon écoutez merci en tout cas de
votre présence merci de votre patience
je pense que vous avez tous l'essentiel
donc qui reprend tous les chiffres que
je vous ai donnés si vous avez besoin
d'éléments complémentaires n'hésitez pas
à nous à nous à nous contacter on est à
votre disposition on vous donne
rendez-vous très probablement à la
mi-juin pour la remise du rapport et
puis d'ici là on va continuer à
travailler avancer pour faire un certain
nombre de propositions sur la ligne de
crête que j'ai exposé mais qui nous
tiennent particulièrement à coeur parce
que je le vois à travers votre présence
et à travers le nombre de réponses et de
sollicitations qu'on a c'est un sujet
qui qui passionne nos concitoyens qui
les intéressent qu'il peut les inquiéter
qui peut être inflammable chère Madame
mais pour autant je pense qu'il faut
pouvoir jouer le jeu de la transparence
de la clarté de leur des choses telles
qu'elles sont et de faire un certain
nombre de propositions concrètes
efficaces et c'est ce qu'on va essayer
de faire avec
l'équipe du Sénat sous la houlette du
président
l'archet du président Longeau de ma
commission et bien sûr de nos
administrateurs que je remercie une
nouvelle fois pour leurs compétence leur
efficacité et leur sourire permanent
merci